Hale Matthew and Sienna here and today
we have a very special guest we have
certified Adobe instructor Daniel Scott
and he's gonna be teaching us the top
five adobe illustrator tools that we
need to know today I got to say this
guy's a wizard when I watched this
tutorial I didn't even know these tools
myself and that shows that one either
I'm a complete novice at Adobe
Illustrator or two I just haven't been
keeping up with the times in any case I
was pretty excited to watch and learn
these things if you're interested in
following along this tutorial we've
provided materials in the link in the
description below let's get into it
hi there Here I am thanks for having me
now who is this video for it's for you
designer who have the latest version of
Illustrator installed and yes still
haven't gone through all the new updates
from the last two or three versions and
worked out how they can really enhance
your workflow that's what I'm here to do
today
so let's get started all right it is
feature number one it's called the shape
builder tool now throughout the video
I'm going to use exercise files okay you
can download those if you want to play
along exactly
there'll be a link in the description
otherwise you can just use your own
files whatever you like totally fine
with me let's get in there okay the
shape builder tool is gonna let us use
that plus one other tool the ellipse
tool and turn now hand-drawn Fox into
sexy curves and shapes let's get started
first up create a blank page doesn't
really matter the size but if you're
copying me I've got a u.s. litter and
landscape next step is to bring in our
hand drawing that will redraw with the
shape builder tool so get a file go to
place and in your exercise files
there'll be a file in there called Fox
jpg now this is just a hand-drawn file
that I've made I find my process often
with things like this I'll draw them in
my workbook first and then redraw them
afterwards in Illustrator and a cool
little trick is when you're bringing in
say a scanned or photographed image that
you've drawn if you click this little
template option as it comes in watch
this when I click place it's pretty cool
cycling off in the background it is
locked it is on its own layer called
plate Fox there's being kind of dimmed
out a little bit and being locked and
it's created this other layer that I
couldn't draw on top so you don't have
to do that but that little template
check box that you've ignored forever
will be handy for a few of you who
follow this kind of process all right
you didn't come for that you came for
the shape builder tool so I'm gonna grab
the ellipse tool so it's hiding
underneath the rectangle tool so just
hold it down hold hold hold
grab the ellipse tool and over here in
your properties panel let's have the
fill so click the white square and use
the little none option which is a line
through it and for the stroke now I
click the black box and I'm gonna pick
like a real bright magenta or remove it
later on but I want to here so you can
see I'm gonna move mine up to maybe two
points a little bit big but hopefully
we'll make it easier to see on the video
so now we need some circles I'll draw
this body piece first just want to draw
our circle and I want it to be a perfect
height and a width so while I'm dragging
it down remember hold down the shift key
that gets a perfect circle X my black
arrow I'm just going to manipulate this
so it kind of fits this bottom curve
here so I'm gonna hold shift and drag it
up bigger I'm gonna fast forward this a
little bit just so that we get our first
circles
I'll copy and paste it one more time and
I'll do this kind of fella in here he
needs to be a little bit smaller so
drink it down me you like this alright
so we've got the basics in there now
this is where the shape builder comes in
now if you're thinking what is the shape
builder for it's a replacement for the
Pathfinder so window Pathfinder if this
is your best friend or at least their
devil you know and you're like a lot of
people and you drag these and you start
clicking this and then go nope edit undo
click on the next one hit it undo until
you eventually find what you need the
shape builder is a replacement for this
you're laughing because that's how you
do it right it's how I do it anyway so
black arrow select everything go to the
shape builder tool it's this fella here
hard to describe arrow with circles and
dots okay and click on that one here now
by default this thing wants to join up
shapes so watch this I can join by
clicking holding and dragging across
these two which is by itself pretty cool
but I don't want to join things okay I
can join them all up it's not really
what I want to do and undo into other
all bits and pieces again to get it to
do the opposite instead of joining hold
down the option key on a Mac or the Alt
key on a PC you'll see that it goes from
plus to a minus and now this is the
magic I'm gonna drag across uuuu how
good is that check across this straight
across and you can just click once I
need that bit though and we're gonna
undo it but you can see how nice and
easy and quick it is to start editing
shapes and that's the shape builder tool
so we're gonna build out this Fox and
then we'll look at coloring and using
the shape builder tool as well it's
another cool little trick we'll do the
next bit together and then I'll speed it
up a little bit so however you want to
draw a line it's going to use the line
segment tool and draw this little line
that goes all the way from one side all
the way through to the other side grab
the black arrow and select everything
you need to grab all the different
pieces go back to my shape builder tool
okay remember what was the key to hold
down to make sure things disappeared
that's right it is o key on a PC and
option key on a Mac and I'm gonna say
you and I'm gonna draw a line through
that line through that Koha so if you're
still using they may be the scissors
tool or the knife tool trying to join
anchor points to get kind of complete
parts
this is super handy because they are
actually instead of just a pile of lines
can you see they're actually joined hole
shapes super helpful all right I'm gonna
speed up the next bit I'll jump back in
when we start adding things all right
you're back and it wasn't really so much
time that I guess I wanted to show you
how to sleep them all and I kind of draw
maybe too many lines at once - I'm gonna
try and impress you with how I can make
them all join you ready you guys will
join them so I'm not holding anything
down now I'm just joining them all up
magically a guy needs to join with that
guy this guy's gone these guys are
drinking it cross then you can click the
months but I find just like dragging
across them works just as well this guy
needs to join up he's gonna grab my last
little lips here I'm gonna do and want
to make sure you slick them all and
after a while you'll start learning this
shortcut which is shift in okay and
that'll jump to this tool you use a lot
like me so you can see it's done a
pretty great job it's not perfect
there's a little artifact left over here
if you do find random things left over
and use my direct selection tool and I
click it once I'm gonna zoom in because
I can't click once it's quite small
there it is there
delete it a couple of times until that
piece is gone let's go to the layers
panel let's turn off that template we
created back to the properties panel
let's color it quickly want to show you
one of the tricks for the shape builder
tool and coloring I'm gonna go to window
I'm gonna go to color themes I'm gonna
explore and I'm going to find foxy color
you type in Fox Fox even one of the cool
things about the shape builder tool
especially if you're an illustrator is
I'm gonna slick that all the black arrow
go to my shape builder tool and what you
can do is you can decide like okay I
like this color so I'm gonna click it
you see it becomes filled over here I'm
gonna say you know in that color and I'm
going to
this for the next color you can just
work your way around a document coloring
now say you wanted to reuse a couple of
colors so I can click and click whatever
your cursor is loaded with or at least
the fills loaded whether you can just
keep clicking away in different parts
anyway I find it a nice helpful tip but
I can't hack that ten there we go give
it a stroke which doesn't work unless
you're on the black arrow stroke goodbye
and then hey presto he's got a big duck
so go behind him because I think it
looks cooler maybe anyway you see the
power of the shape builder tool let's
get on to the next feature all right the
next tool that you can't live without is
going to be the curvature tool now it's
like the pin tool except it's super easy
in comparison even if you are a really
kind of advanced pin tool user check out
the curvature tool I'm pretty good with
the pen tool and slowly but surely I'm
starting to use the curvature tool more
and more let's see why all right with
the curvature tool exercise we're gonna
start with this hand-drawn Whaley thing
and then redraw it using the curvature
tool let's get going
alright to get started open up the file
curvature tool from your exercise files
we've done the same handy trick where
we've put it in that background and
locked it using the template method now
we want to redraw this you could use the
pen tool but I wonder introduce you to
the curvature towards the fourth pull
down here if you don't have the
curvature tool probably means you've got
an older version of Illustrator I'm
using 2019 alright and the way this
works is I'm gonna zoom in a little is
that it really wants to make curves you
can't make it do corners I'll show you
what I mean so I click once little dog
appears nothing really happens they're
not gonna have way around this circle
here I'm gonna click once more again
nothing really happens and then I'm kind
of I'm not doing anything I just clicked
once with my mouse but you can see when
I kind of move my mouse away from it
I've got this lovely curved line joining
up I'm gonna door or one more curve over
here like once member really wants to be
a curve and like pretty much every
drawing I start I forget to turn the
fill to none so I can see what I'm doing
again there's another case I'm gonna
kind of click once there and
click once there it's kind of got a
little bit of weirdness in there you can
fix that up afterwards
now go to this point now I want this to
be a corner not a curve so clicking once
gives you a curve
double-click gives you a corner so click
once for a curve double-click for a
corner click I'm not gonna draw the
spinner I'm gonna show you in the next
tutorial with the width tool so I'm
gonna carry on here into about there
click once cuz I want to be a curve
maybe click again once there you can see
how lovely these curves are naturally it
really wants to be a beautiful curve
rather than the pin tool you've got a
really kind of guess either be a master
of it or fight with it okay no click
once once once just picking once my
mouse you can see those kids ok corner
what was it
double click you got it come on let's
finish this one off you go back I want
this to be a curve click once go into
here let's actually draw this bit so
here I wanted to double click for a
corner click once for a curve double
click you can see how quick and easy
this is just clicking once clicking once
this is a weird bit you're like what do
we do here you know I don't want to be a
curve where I do say you have clicked in
you like oh I thought it had to be a
curve but now it needs to be a corner
how do I go back and change it you just
actually double click it and it turns it
into a corner click once note twice for
a corner once recurve twice for a corner
and get back here you can see I haven't
actually clicked anything it's
previewing it so me it's the wrong thing
so what do I do to override it double
click it you want to be a curve again
double click it again go away just kind
of toggles them back and forth now if
you're like hey you're ignoring this
thing down here and little weakness
going over there don't worry we got the
basics in you can still use your direct
selection tool confounding the anchor
points and it's just like a regular path
and shape okay you can go through and
start modifying it dragging out the
handles add more handles go fix it with
the pin tool if you prefer a little bit
it's gonna drive me mad I know it is
it's actually not too bad alright so
that's the curvature tool it's
definitely better when your new pin tool
can be quite tricky but as you saw there
does block in some really easy flowing
shapes let's use it in combination with
one of the
other tools the shape builder tool so
coverture tool instead of clicking on
the edge here I'm actually gonna do it
all the way through so gonna click once
click again and I'm gonna click once
there because I want it to be curved
click once out here so how many clicks
one two three four and I didn't just
click once of them all because I want
them to be all a nice flowing curve yeah
if it's stuck to this you like the off
hit Escape key on your keyboard that
kind of disconnects it now what I want
to do is kind of slice this into a piece
and color it will also draw the eye I'm
just using the ellipse tool now grab
them all with my black selection tool
grab our handy dandy shape builder tool
and I'm going to hold down the option
key or the Alt key on a PC just to get
rid of these little bits and over here I
want to use my window color themes and
I've just done Explorer and I'm just
looking at the most popular colors at
the moment and I'm gonna pick this one
and use these two colors she and I want
to join these up and color with this
nice look at that combo move
the curvature tool with shape builder
tool all right that's gonna be it for
the curvature tool on to the next
picture all right the next feature is
the width tool it's a way we can draw
two parallel lines that curve around and
actually flow together without spending
two and a half days with the anchor
points and handles and you don't really
know what I mean yet do you
let's jump in and I'll show ya all right
this is what I mean by the width tool
where there's a kind of a curve that
runs along the top and it runs
paralleled on the bottom that's super
easy to do with the width tool also do
something a little bit more fancy like
this where they're these curves and
you'll connect in this little dollop to
the end it's all done with the width
tool it's jumping now and figure out how
all right the width tool is this fella
here looks like kind of a bow and arrow
something click on it you can grab any
line okay I'm gonna grab this one we did
here okay click hold and drag it go up
select off you can see how it goes
through and just kind of does a nice
kind of flowing both sides all running
parallel a little bit of a bump down
here because of my corner boy
and undo that let's look at this option
here we're gonna use curvature tool if
once once once once okay so I've got a
nice curve it's kind of the same as the
one flowing through there how do I get
it to stuff being connected that's right
escape I'm gonna get rid of the fill
color by now what I want to do a curve
like this if I leave this stroke as is I
think the strokes at one point it's
gonna doesn't look as good get it real
low like here lines of 0.25 escape key
again let's get it nice and thin it
doesn't really matter if you drop with
the pin tool the pencil tool the
coverage at all just make sure it's nice
and thin stroke and I'm gonna grab the
width tool and I'm gonna click hold and
drag it in the middle you can kind of
see what I mean right
Izu min a little bit you can see have
you ever done it I've done the pin tool
on the top and then try and do the pin
tail on the bottom to match it and never
seems to flow nicely kind of does it for
us we can do adjustments afterwards
because I want the thickest part to be
about here so you can grab the center of
this I'm still using the width tool you
can just drag it along and say I want to
be about there I can make it a bit wider
okay but let's say you don't want it as
wide the bottom is at the top you can
hold down the option key on a Mac or the
Alt key on a PC okay and just drag one
of these little white squares here to
kind of start adjusting it it's just one
side not the other you can have more
than one point I'm gonna click and drag
here and with the width talks you got a
click hold and drag on that center line
and you can add a different points you
can have different shaped lines you get
the idea right I'm gonna undo that my
drawing was only kind of a suggestion so
I'm happy with the way it is zoom out
before I show you a little bit more of a
hard core use of this tool often what
people want to do is they want to go to
object and they want to go to expand
appearance and it'll turn it from being
like a lovely kind of stroke to a fill
then we could do cool things like I
could join it to this slick both of them
grab the shape builder tool I could say
you and now all one shape so the
technique won't work if it's still a
stroke so I'm gonna undo that because
that's not what I wanted be something
you want to do
at some point all right let's jump to
this other document all right if you
want to follow along open up living
spree from the exercise files this is a
drawing I did a long time ago it's kind
of based on size Scott's he's got that
amazing kind of style with those animals
as trying to do some type stuff with it
but why it's here it's got some really
good examples of the width tool and I
want to show you how to do these we'll
call them head polls the end here you
can do those with the width tool so I'm
gonna lift this eye for us to do so I'll
show you how I did it so I'm gonna grab
the ellipse tool okay and I'm gonna draw
an ellipse if you want to know how to
draw it from the center you hold down
the shift key and the option key on a
Mac or the Alt key on a PC it's kind of
close to where I wanted it right now I
want to slice it off I'll just show you
I've taken to doing this so grabbing the
line segment oh and going steady using
like the scissors tool which would be
perfectly fine okay I select them all
and use the shape builder tool that we
learned earlier and just start to delete
these guys remember holding down the Alt
key the option key on a Mac or dragging
through them just the nice way of
sneaking up lines anyway that's not the
trick the trick is doing the little
tadpoles so grab the width tool now what
I'm gonna do member with the width tool
selected and click hold and drag out
there's a nice big in peace
okay maybe not so big and then just a
bit further along I'm gonna click hold
and drag out a smaller piece that could
be a little tricky
give it a couple of goes maybe you're
clicking and dragging on both the in
piece and a bit further in we're gonna
just tuck it in so it's a little bit
smaller now by default it's probably
going to have this nice and flat in
that's called unfortunately named a butt
cap to change it go to properties go to
stroke and change it from that one to
rounded cap okay and that should give
you the nice little bobble at the end
table and that's kind of what I did with
the rest of these I cannae some of them
might just drew with the curvature tool
and just put a bobble on the end some I
want it to be like a perfect circle
anyway I wanted to show you just a
little bit more of the width tool before
we get on to our next feature all right
I'm left in and I feel like it's better
introducing these new features live so
we get to meet each other see each other
in the next feature that we're going to
discuss together is going to be the
freeform gradient it's cool feature
let's jump inside the computer again and
check it out alright so in this video
we're gonna look at doing gradients
where you can actually just move points
around other than a complex gradient
mesh we're trying to fake it with lots
of radial gradients the freeform
gradient it's super easy to use
really complex gradients and did I
mention it was easy to use right let's
get going
alright from your exercise files open up
the free-form gradient file but you can
use any vector shape this is a logo that
I did a little while ago I spent ages
playing with gradient meshes and linear
gradient to try and get the result I
wanted so a free-form gradient is easy
to apply
so my black arrow I'm gonna click on so
got two separate shapes right so I'm
gonna click on this first option here
over here it says fill I'm gonna pick
just the standard black to white linear
gradient and then kind of just click out
and what you'll notice is with it
selected you've got linear you've got
radio and you've got this new one that's
the magic one freeform gradient click on
that and we'd this happens it does a
really good job while really good job it
has a guess it tries to reach out and
look around the document for the colors
use pick white and black from the
document and the green so what I want
but it's put in some nice dots you might
find there I'm gonna delete these you
can just click and delete them you might
have one sometimes it's a bit weird that
way so I'm gonna undo put them all back
in let's say that you've got three or
one all you need to do to change the
color of it so you've got this white one
you're like I don't want white just
double-click the center ok and you'll
open up either your mixer okay or your
swatches I'm gonna use the swatches
panel for the moment I've got a couple
of colors premix I'm gonna use this
darker green at the top and kind of in
the center here I want to add another
color just the light green all you do is
click once and you get a swatch that
will click it to change the color
remember decide with you using the mixer
or swatches use the lighter green here
you can see how complex this is it's not
just a linear gradient now there's all
sorts of things happening let me show
you a couple other things so
double-click this one I'm going to make
it the dark dark green what else can you
do and
I'm going to click back on it to kind of
close it up this is the extent see this
kind of like circle here you can drag it
out to make it bigger you can see it's
just um a zoom in so we can make it yeah
extend further these are the guys are
just fighting with each other okay who's
got that strong gradient I'm gonna make
this nice and small because I want it
down in there this is where it gets
really nice cuz you're like oh I just
wanted to because a radial gradient
might get you this far but now I
actually want to inject a bit more of
the lighter color here okay and these
guys are gonna fight each other a little
bit close quarters I'm not sure why
they're fighting but you the idea all
right let's go down here actually I want
it to be the light one I'm just messing
around now I'm gonna show you a couple
of other tricks so moving them just grab
the center extent you can delete them by
say you add one and you don't want it
there just have it selected and hit
delete on your keyboard gone to other
features one is you can do a gradient
line so we're just doing its called
points can you see over here says draw
points it means just like these random
points that you can move around delete
them if you need to but you can actually
draw a line which is pretty cool so I'm
gonna grab my black arrow and click on
this chunk what I'd like to do is add
the gradient again so over here this is
fill you use black and whites cuz it
down now click on this one here freeform
gradient edit some random dots what I'm
gonna do is I'll leave that one there
this one here I'm just gonna kind of
move over the side and I'm gonna switch
from points to lines it's better if you
move any existing points away otherwise
they start joining so what it does is
I'm gonna click once and I'm gonna
double click it just to start off with
the right color okay and then kind of
close it back down you either hit escape
on your keyboard or just click on the
dot again what you'll notice is you see
this it's kind of connected to it now it
operates the same way it's the curvature
tool that we learnt earlier on I feel
like I'm never gonna use that tool
he doesn't matter and illustrator has
forced it into a few different tools
like this one so what happens is it
looks like a straight line but remember
when I click once and then move off can
you see it starts wanting to do a curve
I can do a straight line and by kind of
just having one there and one there to
do some ones that are kind of close to
each other
ends up straightening it out you
see I get a nice kind of cool curve that
follows along here I'll kind of
accentuate it by going back to points
and moving some of these guys around you
can start to see it's got this kind of
like green force field okay that follows
that line there so that's kind of what I
want to do I want down here I want
double-click you I want to be black on
it to be the dark green down here be the
dark green again and with hey let
another one ended up you get the idea of
this kind of really complex gradient we
can do all with points that's fine but
the line tool is going to be amazing for
those people who do more illustration in
Illustrator I tend to do logos with
gradients in them so that line option is
going to be amazing for those people
doing full illustration in Illustrator
alright one last thing I promise was you
can do opacity which is really cool all
right an example if I grab the black
arrow click on this one if you want to
get back into editing it you've got to
cook on this option this is edited
gradient ok and let's say this one here
instead of at disappearing kind of dark
I want to actually have the opacity down
on this one okay so it looks like it's
gone white but really what's happened is
let me select at all
zoom out and just drag it over here and
you'll see when it crosses halfway
across this you see there it's not
actually white I guess it's showing
through the background so that can be
really handy as well all right give it
up for the freeform gradient tool all
right let's jump into the next and last
feature alright it's time for the last
feature this one is called global edit
now don't be confused it's at the end
not because it's the fifth of my
favorite beaches it's because it's the
least sexy of them all okay I keep that
really cool-looking ones at the front
but this one's probably going to be the
feature that is gonna change your
workflow life the most so let's jump in
and look at the global edit in
Illustrator alright from the exercise
files open up this one here called
global edit now this document is just an
example of like a mock-up website I did
in Illustrator there's nothing special
about it this will work for you as long
as you're using
one of the later versions of Illustrator
2019 or above alright what it does is
it's for things like this like you've
done a big project where like let's say
this arrow and this button here appears
multiple times I'm gonna got three
outboards here but you can imagine doing
this is just a really simple website
design you're likely to have a whole lot
more pages for a website and lots of
different sizes it could be tens or
hundreds of pages probably not but you
get the idea this thing appears on lots
of documents really handy as well for I
do a lot of design like this say Google
banner ads ok you need to make a change
and with this selected here I want to
change the arrow don't like it it's too
pointy whatever it is I'm gonna zoom a
little bit and I want to change on all
apples what you can do is click on this
magic by its click start global edit and
something magical happens in a zoom out
a lot you can kinda see here I'll zoom
in on the video but you can see there's
these three have been selected across
all the artboards I've done nothing to
them there's nothing like like special
about them they're not symbols it just
magically reached out and grabbed
everything that happened to be the same
shape in color I can go through now grab
my white arrow and say actually I'm
gonna zoom in and stop missing with the
corners here and kind of make it this
pointy and magically let's go over look
at this fella zoom in on him he's less
pointy so is the other guy cool huh all
you do is click on something you like
this orange box is Mandarin box here I
need it to be I need to change it to
panel at the pill shape just click stack
logo later you can see grabs all of them
didn't grab this one because it's not
the right kind of shapes right color
okay and I'm gonna drag these coins if
you there's a little dots for the
rounded corners are super handy you were
like where are those make sure you got
the latest version of illustrator by go
to view and it's this one here it's
called corner widget turn those on and
so yeah super helpful huh let me show
you one more here's my little kiwi down
the bottom here stack global edit you
can see it picked em and hemp now we're
physically changing things it's really
good for color as well and this
highlights an old feature there not
everyone knows let's say that I do like
I want to change this kind of Mandarin
color to something else right I want to
go this has been in here forever it's
under select you can go the same and go
to fill color this is just real handy
this is good for doing like it's gonna
pick every single vector object that has
that fill color and I can go through and
change it okay this might be good when
you don't trying to do some color ways
for a brand you trying to figure out
different styles okay
terrible colors then but you get the
idea right and that's been in there for
a while where global edit is quite
helpful is I'm gonna undo is that say I
licked on this and I don't want a color
I don't you know i don't want to color
everything I just want to color the
circles there's only two of them there's
a couple let's go to let's go to global
edit okay and it's reached out and
grabbed those two guys there okay and it
means I don't have to go through one of
the things though is you see I click on
green it's like it is an updated look
it's not even noticed he's got to kind
of click out of this and eventually
updates amazing huh one of the other
little tricks is if I undo that
what on by default is well I've got this
one selected so I'm gonna click off
click on him okay and down here it says
global edit you can hit this little
arrow here you can add some options so
let's say that I don't want to match the
size I think it's off by default so
yours might be off by default hevachick
I want to stack global edit but I don't
want it to match sizes okay and click on
it you can see it grabbed all the
circles down here it's probably doing it
for you by default but it's just really
handy sometimes later on you're like
actually don't grab those just grab you
drop this down match the size start
global edit and just these two guys will
match go ha a couple of little things
just so you're a pro edit is that down
the bottom here there's you can pick
different app boards and include objects
on canvas that just means anything in
this great area you can include lots of
people end up working in this great area
you want to adjust those as well
make sure that's ticked the other thing
to note as well as that it's not working
for text at the moment if I've got
editable text I can't do global edit I
really like to I'd love to go through
and as you you know pull on these
different fonts and adjust them and
doesn't work for images as well so it's
for actual physical Victo graphic pieces
rather than
and images at the moment all right that
is global edit I'll pass it back to real
Dan to finish this up all right hi
bye thanks for having me I hope you
enjoyed the videos I try to make them
they're a little bit longer I know but I
try and make sure that the tools are
described and they're kind of entirety
so that you can go and start working
with them straight away in your
professional work and know the ins and
outs I'll hand it back over to the
future to do the outro I'll see you
around if you like this video from
Daniel Scott and you want to see more of
him let us know in the comments section
below and let us know what software
package you want us to focus on next if
you want to master your technical skills
consider taking one of Daniels courses
he's a certified Adobe instructor and he
teaches you a range of tools and
techniques from Photoshop to illustrator
to XD and much much more check out the
link in the description below if you got
some value out of this video let us know
by giving us a comment like and
subscribe it really helps us out with
that out of the way it's time to get
back to work